what's this new paper of yours about the
inheritance of social
status so the paper looks at 425,000
people in England over the course of 400
years who are all linked together by
descent and
marriage and just asks what describes
how you inherit social
status and it ends up that there are
actually three very interesting aspects
one is that there's a very strong
inheritance of status much stronger than
people conventionally believe and so
there's an underlying correlation that's
really strong the second astonishing
aspect is that that correlation hasn't
changed over the course of 400 years
there's no more social Mobility now than
the Wass in the 17th century the 18th
century the 19th
century but the most surprising element
of all is that if you want to predict
how correlated people will
be then that prediction is based on
what's their genetic correlation and so
the data is just very consistent with a
really simple model of genetic
transmission where what just matters is
how how many genes do we have in common
that'll explain how much outcome we'll
have in
common uh and uh that as say is for many
people very surprising and also quite
troubling for a lot of people what is
the methodology of you being able to
track genetics across such a long period
of Time how how are you able to do that
presumably ancestry.com wasn't tracking
people 400 years ago right um so the
lineage stuff is is fine and so
basically I was using there there are
all these kind of interesting Societies
in Britain and one is the Guild of one
name
studies and these are two or three
thousand people who've devoted
themselves to following the history of
particular surnames in England and
they've done fantastic jobs kind of
actually tracking people's genealogy
over hundreds of years and so that part
is is is
straightforward but the only thing we
can do here is we don't have we have no
direct genetic evidence here what we can
look at had though is what would be the
predictions of a genetic model of
transmission and that has a distinctive
and very clear set of predictions about
how correlated fourth cousins third
cousins second cousins first cousins
will
be uh and and it all depends on how much
assortment there is in marriage how
strong these correlations will remain
and so there's also you know uh
predictions about siblings about
grandparents
grandchildren and as I say the the very
surprising thing here is that the
predictions of that model are very
consistent with this data for
England uh and it it really is uh you
know so as say so so there's nothing
conclusive here there's nothing
direct but there is just a very
interesting empirical
pattern and then as part of the paper I
also can say well what about other
features of inheritance of status that
would be consistent with genetic
transmission do they also hold and so
here's one example is with genetic
transmission mothers should always have
an equal influence as fathers in terms
of outcomes for children because you get
half of your genetics from each
parent now if we go back to 19th century
England fathers play a very different
social role than they do now
if you look now mothers still actually
spend much more time with children than
do
fathers and so we would actually expect
with social transmission that maybe
sometimes fathers are more important and
other times mothers are much more
important but the data for this lineage
in England is very clear if you want to
predict children's outcomes mothers and
fathers play exactly the same way
and and you know one so early on we have
evidence on the literacy of mothers and
fathers and so that's equally predictive
of what the child literacy would be and
it doesn't matter if it's a boy or a
girl in in those cases it's again
equally predictive for other outcomes
like
occupation we don't have occupations for
women in the 19th century but we can
proxy women's occupations by for example
taking their brother and then taking
their husband's brother and that'll
actually give us a good proxy for what
their occupational status is and then we
can say which predicts child outcomes
better is it the mother's proxy or the
father's proxy and the answer again is
No it's exactly the same weight and so
and that's true as I say all the way
through the last 300 years that mothers
and fathers play exactly the same role
in terms of outcomes except for one
important
outcome and that outcome
is wealth for wealth fathers are much
much more influential than brothers and
that's because wealth tended in England
to flow on the Patra line that men
inherited more family wealth than women
did and so what matters is what's your
grandfather's wealth on the Patra line
as opposed to your grandfather on on the
matal line so as I say there's this this
is one piece of interesting ancillary
evidence a second piece is what's the
effect of birth order on
outcome right and in the social world I
mean I don't know if you have children I
had
three and the oldest child gets much
much more parental attention than the
younger ones do right and talk to anyone
who has children and this is true I mean
the parents a new thing when the first
kid comes along the parents have all
these ideas about how they're going to
shape these kids and so and and
empirically we know that older children
get more attention than younger children
so you might expect that older children
will do much better in terms of social
outcomes uh it turns out in this data no
it's in in almost every case birth order
doesn't matter your chances in life are
the same whether you first or the last
and a lot of the families in the 19th
century there are 10
children and so you would think the 10th
one is coming into this kind of crowded
family there's no more
space my own parents were both from
families of
12 and by the time you know my father
and mother I think both were Number Nine
by the time they came along the housing
is incredibly tight you're sharing a bed
with three siblings and stuff like that
and uh but it turns out it it it it
doesn't matter except again there's a
slight exception for the top 1% of
families in the 19th century the kind of
elite the oldest son is doing better
than the younger Sons but that's the
only thing that matters so the old and
the older son inherits more but is also
more likely to be sent to University
than the younger Sons so you do see
slight deviations for this but for 99%
of the
population it doesn't matter what birth
order is and then another thing you can
look at is what about family size isn't
that going to influence your outcomes
because the more children there are the
less resources there are the less
parental
attention again uh in the era so there's
an era up to marriages of around about
1880 where in England family size was
random people made no attempt to control
fertility and it it is amazing
that they just apparently got married
produced children sometimes there's only
one child you know just the accidents of
fertility in the sample we have there's
one guy who has 27 children from two
different
wives and so you get this enormous
variation in family size and again it
has no effect except for richer families
for wealth and then if you're from a
larger family then your wealth actually
declines right sorry if you're from a
wealthy family and it's larger your
wealth declines because the wealth has
to get divided yeah the if if
inheritance is going to play a large
role in determining your future level of
wealth and there are more people taking
from that pie each sliver of the pie is
smaller yeah right so so as I say so
that's another aspect uh another thing
we can look at is
do you ever need to meet your parents
for them to influence through social
outcomes and so in a lot of the period
that we're looking at uh you know
parental death is occurring at
relatively early ages for some people in
their 50s and 60s and so about 10% of
the kids their father dies before
they're 10 years
old and we can then say how correlated
are you with your father as a a function
of you know you you knew them all the
way up till you're 21 or they died be or
they died before you were 10 it makes no
difference to outcomes you you don't do
any worse in life you're not any less
correlated with your father uh you you
apparently you never need to meet your
parents for them to have exactly the
same influence on your outcomes so so as
I say this study then is based on this
observational data right and so it
doesn't prove anything
directly but I'm working on a book which
is going to have all of this kind of
ancillary
evidence about the nature of social life
and as I say a surprising amount of this
says it's not social transmission it
seems to actually be genetic
transmission that is the consistent
pattern that would explain people's
outcomes when you talk about outcomes
you're using words like social social
status where they end up in life stuff
like that what what what is social
status based on what you're talking
about here right so the specific
measures we have are did you go to
higher education of some
kind
uh what was your literacy earlier on uh
the best one we have is what your
occupational status right and then we
also know for everyone who's most people
who are alive now what's the value of
your house that you're living in and
that's pretty good indicator of your
income level and then also what's the
nature of the neighborhood you're living
in is it one where there's a lot of
educated people there's low crime rates
stuff like that so we have a kind of
measure of and and that's we got down to
the almost the street
level uh what's the quality of of that
and so as I say so we have these kind of
multiple measures but what I've seen
with the data here is that these things
tend to move pretty closely together
that basically High status people have
more education more
wealth higher occupational status they
live in nicer neighborhoods uh they tend
to live
longer uh all of these things and that's
why I I think of it inherently as
there's there's just some underlying
kind of social abilities that people
have and that that's the thing that's
being transmitted between the
generations it's interesting to think
about how you've tried to tease apart
social transmission and genetic
transmission or genetic inheritance I
suppose because a lot of people would
look and say well you know if you come
from a family that is well off think
about the culture that you have around
the house around the dinner table think
about the sorts of things that are being
spoken about think about the kind of
friends that you're going to play with
that your parents are going to have
you're going more likely to go to after
school clubs you're more likely to maybe
have a tutor or maybe be encouraged to
play sports or to play a musical
instrument or all of these different
things and yet it seems like behavioral
genetics wins out yet again yes and so
uh now now it turns out uh I didn't you
know because I'm coming from an
economics and kind of History background
and I just got interested in this and I
had this data and I thought well let's
try if we fit a genetic model what would
happen uh in this field is very fractur
and very kind of IDE kind of ideology is
very important to people and it turns
out most of the people actually don't
want to believe that simple genetic
transmission plays an important role in
social life and so most of the people in
this field actually seem to believe that
cultural transmission of the type that
you've described is actually very
significant and very
important but there is one kind of
puzzling thing about that which is
people don't focus on this a lot but
there's a lot of variation within any
family in terms of the outcomes for
children and children's outcomes are no
more correlated than and they have
roughly the same correlation as between
a parent and a child what they cor you
know the correlation of child outcomes
now if you really believe strongly in
cultural
transmission I you know when I look at I
was one of four children if I look at
the expectations my parents had of us if
I look at the dinner table conversations
I sat around in if I look at the housing
we lived in the neighborhood we were in
it's all the same for all four of us and
so if you really believe cultural
transmission you would expect that
siblings really would show very very
strong strong correlations right because
you have you have essentially the same
environment for all siblings right but
and the only thing that would have been
the only variable that you would have
had would have been some sort of uh
genetic one that you got this particular
combination of sperm and egg and
somebody else got the rest right and and
so it turns out then that the one and
people don't seem to focus on that a lot
that there is this puzzle with cultural
uh transmission which is how do you
explain why uh siblings are actually
significantly different and and now with
with genetic things that is partly
because you inherit different genes from
each parent but a lot of it is just
because whatever genetic blueprint you
have there's a Randomness about what
body eventually gets assembled from that
blueprint and that means that even
identical twins are not identical in
terms of their phenotype
right and you know people there's this
very famous investigator of twins
plen um he had a whole project which
sought to look in detail at families
where you had identical twins and one
was different from the other you like
one went to college and one didn't and
he interviewed the twins he interviewed
all their relatives I think they spent
years doing this in detail analysis and
it came up with conclusion in the end
they could find nothing that would
actually explain why these differences
existed and so I say I think there
actually it's something again where
genetic explanation has this idea well
this this this irreducible Randomness
about
life and and about how the genetic
instructions get implemented and that
explains why even identical twins will
not turn out to be
identical um and so uh uh so so I say so
so cultural explanation is this
interesting uh alternative
um the it it's hard to test right
because someone could say well I believe
in culture but I believe it has exactly
the same form of transmission as would
come through
genetics and then you know it's such a
loose form of
explanation right because everyone has
their own ideas about how culture
operates what matters is it that you
know you have some figure in the family
that you can look up to is it the actual
contact that matters is it the schooling
that people go to um and so it's very
hard to um to find you know stuff that
would refute a kind of cultural
explanation because inherently unlike
the genetic explanation it's just not
super well kind of specified but as I
say I think the strongest thing is this
fact of the way siblings vary within
families and the fact that it's very
hard to then to to understand why a
sibling number one is doing great
sibling number two is struggling when so
much is common in terms of people's
backgrounds and as siblings when they're
growing up why do you think it is that
this genetic explanation of social
inheritance and social status is so
ideologically
unpopular um but well it absolutely
seems to be because it's it's saying
somehow mechanically at Birth your life
chances are pretty much determined right
and that uh the state or Society is not
going to be able to do very much to
actually change outcomes right and so it
implies a kind of relatively
conservative social policy because it
would say oh the expenditures on schools
and other things like that are really
not going to have that much effect in
terms of of social
outcomes uh and so I think it's that and
then also people are worried immediately
about what does that imply about uh the
relative fertility of G different groups
in society and the implications of that
what is you mean about relative
fertility oh because once once you say
look what's happening is the that one
person is successful in life because
they have this genetic material and
another person is unsuccessful because
they don't have the favorable genetic
material then the issue immediately
comes up well you know if this first
group was to multiply and increase their
share of society there would be all of
these potential soci social benefits if
the other group was not to do that there
would be an avoidance of social costs
and so people are I think rightly
very concerned about the potential
social implications of this but the only
problem is I mean when we're thinking
about how the world
is it's very it's it's very important
not to to ad do certain positions just
because it would make life easier right
uh I mean when you're thinking about you
know the way the the world is actually
operating uh the important thing is is
never to have theend view in sight in
terms of what explanation do I favor
what explanation do I find plausible
here I mean we'll just have to live you
know whatever this the explanation is if
it turns out genetics really is
important we'll just have to live with
those
consequences uh what is
sorry what what is the consequence of
ignoring the genetic
implication um well I there's there's
several consequences one is for example
I
think as a society we've come you know
and and I should say as a background
Point here I've made my life working in
education but it's firmly my belief that
we've vastly exceeded the amount of
Education that people should usefully
get in this Society right that and and
we've done that in part because it's
been regarded as the key to to social
Mobility social advancement leveling the
playing
field and now we're adding forever now
instead of just getting a ba people now
think that they have to get a master's
degree uh there's there's actually you
know the empirical evidence that
education is actually improving people's
lives is actually very weak uh but
didn't you say didn't didn't you say
previously that one of the
uh parameters that you'd used was
education level whether or not they did
get to higher education so you saying
that that as a useful indicator of
someone's future life outcomes is
becoming less and less effective at
being predictive uh I I I yes uh here's
an example of of why this doesn't seem
to be very predictive so in the UK at
various stes we've extended the amount
of compulsory schooling that people get
so I think like 1973 46
1919 we've and we move from 12 Years to
14 years 15 years 16 years I think now
it's supposed to be closer to 18
years we can actually look at those
episodes and you get then two corts of
people you get the people from just
before the change who get on average you
know they only have to be there till 15
and then you suddenly get a new cohort
who on average get a half a year of
extra
schooling and then you can look
empirically and say well what happened
did that improve these people's life
outcomes and the answer for Britain is
no none of these adjustments to
education showed up in any way as an
improvement in uh you know income or uh
mortality uh longevity none of these
things were actually changed and also
have this house value evidence so you
can say did the people who got an extra
half year of Education end up living in
a slightly nicer house or in a nicer
neighborhood the answer is no okay and
so so so as say that I mean the problem
is that we've we're now spending about
10% of national income on education in
various
forums and in part as I say this is
really driven by this idea that path to
kind of universal social Mobility
is to get everyone
educated and I think that's an
illusion and that you know there there
are other things we could spend that
income on one of the things we could do
is just we could just redistribute more
money to people at the lower end of the
income
Spectrum uh rather than thinking that
everything has to go through something
like education and so you know I'm here
in Denmark now Denmark is I think one of
the most equal Societies in the world
and it's quite impressive what they've
actually achieved in Denmark there's
there's not a lot of homeless people
there's um you know this the state will
provide for you and you know the the
labor market seems to provide pretty
well for people the minimum wage is
something like 20 or 25 pounds
effectively in this society and so you
know I think there's a lot of social
policy that's actually very useful and
very
helpful
and that if we think that the things we
have to spend on are stuff like
education in order to improve social
Mobility I think that's can end up just
in a lot of waste of resources in this
Society shouldn't assortative mating
nudge this stability isn't that kind of
a little bit of a dice role what what
role does marriage play in in this well
it it turns out in in the data that I'm
looking at that's the that's the key
element of the story is that we can
measure a sort of of meeting it turns
out Britain has fantastically good
marriage records because the the
marriage record in uh England and Wales
at least uh from 1837 onwards it
actually asks uh what is the father of
each part and what's the father's
occupation and what's the husband and
wife's occupation and then also earlier
on it also effectively measures literacy
and so it actually you know there's a
lot of information on these marriage
records and the government is sitting on
something like0 million of these and uh
but it costs I think1 pounds to to order
one of them but there's a bunch of kind
of freelance amateur anarchist geneal ol
ists who've said about going to the
record offices and recording this data
and and setting it up on a website and
so we were able to get about 1.5 million
of these records from this
site and what's evident in that data is
that people are matching very very
closely in
marriage uh and that that's consistent
and not changing in England all the way
from 1837 till now and that when people
somehow in marriage What mattered to
people was the underlying social status
of the person they were marrying and
that is something that has very big
social consequences
because a it's going to mean that the
inheritance of status is much stronger
and if what was happening is that men
just married a random woman right so
suppose men the only thing they cared
about was the physical attractiveness of
their spouse and they married in that
way then the parents would not be very
strongly correlated in status and
consequently the children will not be
very strongly correlated with any
individual parent because just to
interject that a woman's attractiveness
has a negligible or not at all
relationship between her social status
right and and and and so so we could
imagine that kind of model of marriage
and what that'll do then is also over
time it would result in less
distribution of abilities in
society right because what's happening
is very high status people marry only
very high social abilities
people then you get over time a widening
of the distribution of abilities in
society and so who decides to marry whom
actually has these huge social
consequences in terms of how strongly
status is passed on but also in terms of
what's the overall distri bution of
abilities within
society and so uh with the marriage
pattern that you're observing in Britain
then uh this is what is actually driving
this very slow social mobility and you
could actually predict with genetic
transmission that if you just force
people to marry at
random you would actually almost double
the rates of social mobility in British
Society uh that's the redistribution
strategy that that we should be pushing
toward none of this education stuff just
get people to get people to mix the
social status that they're marrying
within more that's right if you just
gave them a random here's someone's ID
number or something I guess they don't
have an ID in Britain but here's here's
your number yeah uh and and and this is
actually very interesting and so so
we've actually done some work uh on
another aspect of marriage which it it
was widely believed that the way
marriage works is that somehow women
tend to marry up the women trade
off uh physical attractiveness for
status in males and studies definitely
show that when people report their kind
of Ideal marriage partner that women
report more about income or education
stuff like that and Men report more
about physical appearance right and so
so we were expecting potentially in this
data to find that when we had this huge
collection of marriages that women on
average would be somehow moving upwards
in this you know pattern and and men
would be marrying women of somewhat
lower status now the only way that can
actually work in society if everyone's
marrying everyone then you've got to
have equality in terms of status but
what easily can happen is that it could
be that high status women who are not
physically attractive find it difficult
to find mates and then low status
men whatever their characteristics are
also find it difficult to find
mates and the interesting thing for the
English data all the way through is that
there's absolutely no sign of this on
average man and women are marrying
people of equal status and that's you
know and it's the same pattern for right
at the top of the distribution and right
at the bottom of the distribution and so
somehow the way marriage is operating in
practice is that people are just
matching up mainly on their kind of
social
status and that you you actually not
getting this uh as I say marrying up by
women or marrying down by men and so so
that's a kind of interesting social
aspect of our society which is why do
people choose to marry in that way right
it's not
obvious that that's going to be the
happiest marriage or the ideal marriage
why would it be that people people seem
to care so much about someone's kind of
underlying status but I think what what
this reflects is that when you're dating
someone uh we have these very imperfect
measures as social scientists about how
many years have you been to school
what's your occupation what's your
income people getting married actually
have much much more information you can
tell by talking to someone for not that
long A Time what's their sense of humor
humor what's their
knowledge how smart are they how clever
are they how imaginative are they and
that it's interesting that these things
seem to matter a lot when people get
married and that they're leading to this
kind of very tight assortment of people
at very similar levels in the kind of
social hierarchy uh and as I say they're
underpinning this tendency to have just
a lot of persistence across
Generations yeah so your research points
out that historically men tended to pair
with women who have fathers with similar
social status to themselves that's
correct yeah as men fall behind women in
education do you think that women will
begin to pair with men who have fathers
of similar status to
themselves um oh so now this yes this is
clearly happening that that women are
getting more years of education uh the
difference in earnings Is Not Great
still I think men are still ahead in
terms of earnings um but yet but I think
what's just will happen is that there's
a ranking of males as prospects in the
marriage market and there's a ranking of
women and so now women are actually
going to typically marry men potentially
who have less level of education but I
think the relative ranking is going to
remain the same yeah so maybe women will
be likely to evaluate the education of
her dat's father before deciding to
commit to a date like does this man have
the education genes even if he himself
did not attend college right so one of
the um interesting aspects of the data
that I have is that uh it turns out if
you want to
predict for a given marriage how well
the children are going to do in life
there's a huge amount of information in
the relatives of the people getting
married and so in fact if you wanted to
set up a new dating service you could
actually tell people here's the optimal
waiting of the uncles the aunts the
grandparents and stuff like that that if
you just want to maximize what your
social prospects of your children are
this would constitute the ultimate match
then right so you don't genealogical
dating yeah that's right and then you
could get these algorithms now that
would actually uh tell you you know this
would be a significantly you know better
child in terms of social
outcomes if you were to to match in this
way uh and so um yeah so so as I say it
is interesting because people as when
they're matching they they look like
they're trying to maximize the prospects
for their
children right in terms of the choosing
a mate right uh and uh and I see that's
an interesting social feature I don't
know why we would tend to do that
because it's it's not not true in all
societies so for example if you go to
large parts of the Middle East now or
even uh Native American communities in
South America cousin marriage is still
very
common where you end up actually having
very restricted Choice as to who you can
marry and so that in that type of
marriage you're actually less able to
assort even though you're marrying your
cousin which is kind of ironic uh that
you're that these actually will be more
different socially than the way people
are actually marrying in somewhere like
England so they're actually Achi
wow wow that is so insane that if if
left to random chance people will find
on the street someone who is closer to
their family social status than someone
who is actually a part of their own
family yes no that's an amazing feature
yes but it is actually true that is
Bonkers that is completely
Bonkers um so yeah so so as and and the
other thing that was amazing about this
is that this pattern as I say the the
the new source of marriage data starts
in
1837 that um pattern is there
immediately in 1837 even though at that
time most women didn't formly have
occupations and and so the way we're
able to judge how well they're matching
is to look at the parents to look at the
fathers and see how closely are they
correlating in terms of this marriage
pattern and and so as I say this is a
time when most of these women that men
were marrying were going to be engaged
mainly in raising
children but still when they married
they wanted someone of kind of very
similar social position uh to
themselves um and and and so as I say so
so it's it is a a surprising feature
of the nature of marriage in this
Society yeah does this mean by the way
one thing I should add is part of the
reason I've taken up this position in
Denmark is actually to get access
Denmark has this amazing set of kind of
register data where everyone here has an
ID number and every action in your life
is recorded under that ID number and the
government then so this is true of
Norway Sweden Finland
Denmark uh social scientists come to
these societies because you know they to
take just one example I've seen a paper
which looks at people's earnings and its
correlation and connection with the
psychiatric medications that they were
prescribed this is the real surveillance
State who knew that Scandinavia was the
real surveillance State dear God now
they don't reveal any individual
information but as I say they they have
this amazing set of data here and so one
of the things we wanted to look at is
well is this pattern you see in England
is that just peculiar to England or yeah
I mean that was my f my first question
England uh very classist system uh very
well established we use words like Posh
you know it is still very
ingrained uh accent denotes status an
awful lot the school that you went to
grammar schools the introduction of
things like that old boys clubs gated
communities all that sort of stuff very
prevalent in England what's the
likelihood that this is a quirk
exclusive to just the United Kingdom
right and uh yes and so the reason I
actually was interested here was to say
can we look at say modern Denmark
because everyone thinks of this as a
very high Mobility Society it's very
egalitarian and very different now uh
there's a study that's been done in
Sweden where they've managed to assemble
a kind of a similar kind of panel of
relatives but actually in this case
they're just looking also across people
who married so they're looking at who's
what's the connection between you and
your
brother-in-law you and your
brother-in-law's wife's
cousin where they assemble 141 different
types of relatives and some of them go
across five marriages right with this
data they have they can actually link
you to people who you never are actually
going to meet in social life but you
know your five marriages apart and what
is interesting
is people maintain a correlation in
outcomes like education even across five
marriages right that's how strong these
Social Links are and when we look at
then how strong that correlation is in
marriage in Sweden it's the same
strength is in England people are
matching up in the same way in marriage
in terms of their underlying status and
they have this very slow implied rate of
social Mobility also in a place like
Sweden and so I think this is this is a
general kind of maybe North European or
european probably all of Europe kind of
pattern right and I don't know what it's
going to be like in in some other
societies I suspect it's not going to be
that different right when I read about
places like China and the kind of things
that people are looking for in terms of
mates in China and so I think you know
the British have you know and and I've
you know I say I grew up in Scotland and
then spent I was an undergraduate in
England and then I've spent a lot of
time in
America the British actually keep
beating themselves up that somehow they
have a uniquely class-ridden
and classist Society but there's
actually no evidence of that right I
mean social we just like to abuse
ourselves you know I mean we will find
something to feel ashamed about just
that Puritan that Puritan work ethic as
I'm whipping myself with a cat of nin
Tales that's what we're here for you
know and and it turns out so I I grew up
in Glasgow in a fairly kind of gritty uh
area and so I had a good friend there
who uh became an oil Trader in London
and was became very successful you know
and he went to University before he did
that
he actually has married a woman who is
from a very distinguished family in the
English upper
classes uh and you know and and
clambering out of the muck and the mire
one rung at a time congratulations
mate so so as say so I've even seen in
kind of personal life that there is kind
of you
know quite a lot of social Mobility my
and also from studying engl England in
the past um there's this group The
honuts Who arrived in England in the
1680s and they were Protestant refugees
from
France and relatively educated but they
you know they had their own religion uh
they had spoke
French um they it's amazing how quickly
they assimilated into the upper reaches
of English
society and people with these hugenot
surnames which are quite
distinctive by 1800 they were 30 times
more likely to go to Oxford or Cambridge
than the average person in England right
and so you know so you think about these
places as you know exclusive old boys
clubs stuff like that but the experience
of English society is that there there
definitely is this upper class there are
these fancy schools there's eaten
there's Harold there's all the rest of
that stuff but my experience looking at
this is that it's a very open upper
class if you've got the money the
education the
connections door the door is actually
open keep okay so does this mean largely
that people who are in the upper class
are locked in across time you mentioned
that one of your friends has managed to
clamber out of the blood and the feces
and the hay and get get up in get up
into the high futing upper
troposphere over time did these people
uh like revert back to the mean revert
back to their
mean um well I mean the important thing
about the as I say the upper class is
that there there's you know it's slow it
takes about 300 years but the there's a
universal force of kind of regression
into the meat so we go back and take
people 300 years ago who are the most
elite people in society I mean it's
taken a long time for it to happen but
there is this un ival tendency to move
downwards if you're an elite and if
you're at the bottom there's an equal
tendency to move up and that's one of
the astonishing features of social life
looking at this genealogy is the people
in the bottom
10% they're the ones whose kids have the
most Prospect of upwards
mobility and you know it's very hard to
actually then uh kind of stop people
falling into poverty because it's not
that you can go and find the bottom 10
of people and say okay they are the ones
we need to treat because it turns out a
lot of people who are falling into
poverty are people who are coming from a
bit higher in the social Spectrum who
just have bad luck and kind of moved out
wow right and so so that you know one
thing that's actually interesting to me
is so I've spent a lot of time studying
economics and frankly we've accomplished
almost nothing I don't know why there's
a Nobel Prize in the economics because
you know we can predict what the outcome
of the economy is going to be next year
we can't predict which are going to be
growing economies which are declining
macroeconomics is just a random effect
but when it comes to social Mobility
there at the group Level Society is
actually you see really almost a kind of
physics of social Mobility yeah so if I
tell you you know here's a here's a
thousand people who have the top one %
of social status I can predict pretty
much exactly where their children will
be for the next 10
Generations that's insan just think
about that sentence that you've just
said there that's like Clairvoyance or
divination or something right no I mean
what it is just saying that at least the
You can predict for any individual right
and for every individual family there's
different path there's a lot of
Randomness right so that's the thing
that when you say to people is look the
the the good news is your outcomes don't
seem to be entirely determined by
genetics there's also complete
Randomness as
well fantastic fantastic where's the
where's the agency in this oh don't
worry about that don't worry about that
there's some dice being rolled somewhere
by a God right yeah I mean this is this
is uh pl's Maxim right genetics to do
not predetermine but they do
predispose and when you smear that
across enough of a populace you end with
just like like thermodynamics right it's
like winds that blow in particular
directions and they encourage particular
outcomes right no I mean what so what is
impressive actually I so this is why I'm
actually I'm always a little
surprised by
how how kind of exercised people are
about class and social Mobility right
because somehow there is this kind of
feeling that that that there is this
permanent Advantage group that they're
able to take advantage of their position
all the time and you know get all of
these unearned
benefits um if you look at people who
are at the top 1% of the society what is
more impressive is whatever wealth they
have they're not able to stop their
children moving downwards on average
because of regression to the main yeah
and they're not there's nothing they can
do that I mean I can I can bro bro
science and expl for why that is which
is that most people aren't able to look
longitudinally at anything they're able
to look at things during their period of
life and when they came in these people
were at the top and when they go out
those people are at the top you know
maybe there's some movement but this
regression to the mean happens over long
long long periods of time it's this
generation this gener this idiot child
that decides to gamble his money away
this you know drunk this blah blah blah
blah blah slowly just chips and chips
and chips away but anybody that's using
this sees a them and an us it's a tribal
game and they've been at the top and
they will always be at the top and this
is exactly why the Rockefellers or the
lizard alien people or whoever it is
that's in charge of the world have
always been there and will always be
there yeah no I I agree I mean
the uh yes as I say it's hard for people
to take that kind of long perspective
and and even you know modern uh
economists or sociologists often are
just looking at the current generation
the earlier generation so one kind of
nice thing about the field I'm in which
is looking at you know people 300 or 400
years is that you really can see that
Dynamics play itself out and you can and
and the other thing that you can see is
that all of these incredible social
changes with political franchise
education Social Services all the rest
of that stuff hasn't fundamentally
changed British
society that that we we could be living
in the Victorian era it's the same era
yeah I mean and the the obvious the
obvious question is what's the
implication of this
for a a society that prays at the altar
of
meritocracy like what what what are the
implications you put all of this data
together you realized this sort of a
thing what does this mean like what what
what are the implications
well one implication is that I is I
think that Society is more meritocratic
than people tend to
believe that people with
ability tend to be able to move up
within the society right and and people
without ability are tending to move down
no matter what their parentage was or
what advantages they got from their
parentage and that that people tend to
be overfocused on this kind of absence
of meritocracy or the importance of your
kind of lineage and your class stuff
like that and so one thing I actually
draw is some kind of sense of we do live
in a surprisingly meritocratic world now
in other terms in terms of social policy
um
one implication one immediate
implication for example is if you look
at the experience of the hugenots coming
to
England their descendants
are still five times as likely to go to
Oxford and Cambridge than the average
person in England 300 years later so one
kind of interesting implication of this
is that if you're concerned about the
output of the society as a whole or the
social functioning of the society as a
whole then in Immigration policy you
should really look seek out High status
immigrants right uh because they would
that not would that would that not push
down the social mobility of the native
population it would but but it would you
know that group will eventually be
assimilated into the society as a whole
and so if we look you know five
generations from now the society as a
whole will be better off you have a more
productive populace right but it is true
you know if you have Elite immigrants
then they tend to displace the upper
classes whereas if you have low status
immigrants they that tends to favor the
upper classes in the society and it
tends to compete with people at the
lower end of the society but it does say
that uh you know immigrants are actually
going to have a surprising kind of
long-term impact on the society they're
not just going to be absorbed and leave
the society otherwise unchanged right
because you've taken a a kind of a
hermetically sealed genetic bomb and
you've deposited it and the after sh
shock the after effect of that is going
to continue down the road right and and
and now it it turns out so one of my
co-authors Neil cumins has done some
study you know because I'm of Irish
Origins uh he's years about he was born
in Ireland uh Irish immigrants to
Britain are still somewhat of an
underclass in Britain uh even though a
lot of them have been in Britain for 100
or 150 year more years doesn't bu well
for the Irish
genetics so so yes as I say so if it
ends up if that is really because of the
uh the genetics of that population it's
kind of interesting that it's it it
actually has an impact for for very long
uh
time uh and so so because there are some
FS that would say look everyone has
exactly the same
potential you know so when immigrants
come in it doesn't matter what their
educational background is what other
things are because thr them in a primary
school and a secondary school and get
them a six form degree and they're going
to be just the same and it's it's it'll
make no long run impact on the
society uh but as I say I think if you
really do believe that there is this
element then it would say well in
Immigration policy so so some societies
for example like Australia New Zealand
and Canada have these incredibly
restrictive immigration policies where
basically they want you only if you're
pretty highly
educated uh and what that would say is
that will actually have kind of
longlasting impacts on those Societies
in terms of average educational levels
average ability levels uh and uh so
that's but other than that you know look
people choose to have children they
choose not to have children they will
have these social consequences it would
have the social consequences if it's
transmitted also just by social media
yeah there there's an interesting
there's an interesting question given
that we've got uh declining birth rates
at the moment uh for the first time in
quite a while and the particular cohorts
that are choosing to reproduce are uh
assorting as well uh it seems like
people who are more right leaning are
having
proportionally less fewer children than
people who are left left leaning uh
Downstream from that that has to select
in some ways for social status
educational achievement so on and so
unless it's totally random which it
could be but it seems unlikely that that
would be the case uh have you got a
prediction given the changing birth rate
of what this is going to do to the
inheritance of social status well uh it
turns out there have been some studies
in England because they've got this
thing the UK biobank and so the UK
biobank has metrics of what your
educational potential is based on your
genetics
and base Britain dear God uh but uh then
you can they can actually people can
look at it and say well how many
children do people have based on what
their educational genetic educational
potential is and the answer is it's very
slightly uh what's called dis genic that
is there's a very slight tendency for
people with lower potential just genetic
potential to to have more children but
but it's really not that significant but
what is actually interesting again
looking at this data in the past in
England is that these forces of relative
fertility across different groups were
really big in the past and so in the
period leading up to the Industrial
Revolution the upper classes in Britain
were
Superfund and we're basically having 50%
more children than the the lower classes
in each generation and so you do see
this period where if you think if it is
the case that this all based on genetic
potential that the average abilities of
England were
Rising immediately after the Industrial
Revolution we moved to a completely
different phase where the upper classes
just gave up having children and within
like one generation they move from
having three or four on average children
to having one child it's amazing ly
quick
transformation and so then actually you
enter this other period where you are
and this is the period where the new
genesis are all running around because
they were responding to what they saw as
this incredible social problem but then
since I think the 1960s or something
like that there hasn't been that much
change but there are actually these
periods in the past where you would
actually get these significant changes
in what average ability levels would be
in
has there been any other unique step
change uh in the last recent history uh
that means that some of the rules and
lessons that we've taken from 1600 to
200000 or whatever uh May no longer
apply the introduction of uh hormonal
birth control and reliable
contraception uh the introduction of
homeschooling or of the internet or you
know like is there anything that you
think is a potential step change a
difference of kind not just a difference
of degree when it comes to the
influences on this
stuff um to be honest with you no I mean
I actually think that uh people look at
all the new technologies we have and
everything else and they think oh
fundamentally you know social life must
have dramatically changed and the
possibilities have dramatically changed
but uh you know that other than the
decline in the number of children we're
really not seeing a lot of change in the
nature of social life in Britain it it
hasn't changed that much since you know
the the pre-industrial era uh and uh you
know there's a surprising kind of
constancy to the way people live family
life the way people produce children and
stuff that other than the fact they just
have many fewer of them um and so so
yeah I'm not expecting any great social
revolutions from things like you know so
things like assisted reproduction
technology that's become important it
kind of favors upper class people
because it's expensive and you know so
it it's going to affect potentially
relative fertility but I think it's
still the case that it's a kind of
minority of all children are born in
that way and so I I don't see it as
having dramatic impacts now the one
thing that is on the
horizon that would be kind of personally
I would find a little bit worrying are
you going to talk about embryo selection
yes there it is ivg embryo selection I
knew
it so uh I have talked to some of the
people who are who are have got Venture
Capital now and are trying to develop
these Technologies now the thing about
embrya selection
is currently you've got to look among
among your own embryos right and so
there isn't that much it's not
modification it's selection yeah yeah
there's not that much range but I would
be convinced that in somewh like China
they will go ahead with this right and
and mean one illustration of this is now
in the United States it's you know it's
quite common for upper class parents to
think well a a kind of a nice Pathway to
a good college is if their kids are good
at
Athletics and so there are all there
used to be all these slots where you
could be on the hockey team you know at
Harvard
uh a whole bunch of those middle class
parents were giving growth
hormones to their perfectly normal size
children in order to gain them create
some stud that would go get into an Ivy
League education yeah and and you know
and costing a huge amount of money I
mean this stuff is incredibly expensive
and you know if parents are willing to
do that right if they're willing to take
you know someone who's 5 foot 10 and say
we're going to take you to the special
doctor and get you these growth
hormones um then people will engage in
embryo section so I don't I don't
disagree I I do think that it plays into
at least the the use of growth hormone
plays into
the highly environmental highly uh um
culturally influenced non behavioral
genetic non-genetic determinism view of
the world I think that the upper classes
are going to have to square the
circle of accepting behavioral genetics
as as powerful of a force that it is
because publicly the luxury belief that
is often put forward is you know we just
need to do more welfare and we need to
do so on and so forth and it doesn't
really matter you know you haven't got
this determinism through genetics and
stuff that's perilously close to
Eugenics that sounds an awful lot like
something that Adolf Hitler would have
spoken about mean while they're mating
assortatively uh but they they are going
to have to ultimately put their money
where their mouth is with regards to
this because if certain families that
decide to use embryo selection and then
maybe even Gene enhancement embryo
enhancement techniques uh they're going
to fall behind it's an arms race
ultimately for Offspring and those
people are going to fall behind yeah I
mean the at least the evidence in the US
is if you look at how much people are
willing to spend for private schooling
which it it's unclear how much advantage
that has but they're spending 50 or
60,000 a year on stuff like that and so
I'm I'm confident in place like the US
they would do this but I'm even more
confident in a place like China that
they would do this I mean because there
people are are trying to have boys as
opposed to girls and stuff like that and
they're willing to abort a fetus if it's
the wrong
gender uh and and so I actually I I do
fear that you know and and they're only
people who want to break down that
barrier and push you know us towards
these Technologies the only thing is I
mean things like educational outcome
depend on like a thousand different Loi
on the genome and so it's not going to
be easy to education Gene that we just
need to Tinker with yeah right you know
so there's no simple uh
solution uh to that uh but but it you
know it it seems for sure that that
stuff like that will will come in in
future and um and then I mean the the
other puzzle will be will people just
decide well maybe I I don't need my
partner's
egg I get some other egg I like I like
you as a wife around the house but your
genetics yeah does this really smart
girl at
work so uh so so so there you know it it
will be interesting to see uh what
people uh do but I think I mean the
advice for upper class parents now is
you should just enjoy your children
right if you really are upper class
they're unlikely to exceed you in terms
of their outcomes in life they're more
likely to move towards the mean and so
if you're having children it should be
with that realization that you know
that's just the nature of social life I
I can't resist when I'm teaching
students I should never do this I'm sure
they hate me I actually point out to
them that since they actually represent
an upper class
group if there's 50 of them here in the
class it's predictable that their
children will do less well in life than
they
will all of this hard work to give your
children the advantage so that they can
slip down this snake and just end up a
little bit behind where you were y so I
I've got to in future the resolution to
self do not point this out did you see
this new study on physical
attractiveness and intergenerational
social Mobility that came out recently
oh I don't think I did so Alexa
gush and Gregor bulak I've absolutely
butchered that physical attractiveness
matters both for males and females
intergenerational social Mobility
outcomes but it is more important for
males even when childhood
characteristics were accounted for using
data of about 11,000 individuals from
the United States national longitudinal
study of adolescent Health we contribute
to the existing scholarship by
investigating a physical attractiveness
assessed when individuals are around 15
years old is an important predictor of
intergenerational social Mobility
measured after 20 years results we found
that physical attractiveness matters for
both male and female's intergenerational
social Mobility outcomes but it is more
important for males even when childhood
characteristics such as various aspects
of Parental socioeconomic position IND
idual Health appr proxy for IQ
neighborhood conditions and interview
fixed effects are accounted for using
imputed data for observations with
missing information across three
measures of social Mobility education
occupation and income physically
attractive males are more likely to be
socially mobile than males of average
attractiveness conclusion physical
attractiveness is an independent
predictor of intergenerational social
Mobility outcomes regarding individuals
educational occupational and income
attainment so so uh couple I actually I
haven't seen that paper I do need to
actually go look at it now uh but um one
thing that's interesting there again is
you you would expect from the
conventional wisdom that it would be
women who would actually be the ones for
physical attraction would matter more
than men but what I can tell you is that
someone has just produced a working
paper on
economists where they've actually
identified their physical attractiveness
and found that more attractive
economists have do better in terms of
publication and and I don't know what
they must have gone to the websites of
universities or something like that and
then scraped these things and then had
someone rate them uh and there as I say
the puzzle is Journal editors not
normally look at pictures of people you
know when the paper comes in and say
well how handsome or how tall is this
person uh and so I suspect for these
things that probably
um physical attractiveness is just
another part of social
competence that basically highly
competent people know to get a nice
haircut you know and occasionally shave
and stuff like
that and that uh that that it's really
just another kind of imperfect indicator
of basically what people's kind of
overall social abilities
are what was the response when you
dropped this paper
oh this the the pnas paper well well
you'd probably have heard about that I
got cancelled at Glasgow
University so tell that give us give us
that story but but that was in some
sense that was my fault because I had
published two books each with a
Hemingway pun so my first book was A
Farewell to Arms a brief economic
history of the world the second book was
The Sun Also Rises surnames and social
mobility and so there's a great pun that
involves uh genetic transmission and so
that is for whom the bell curve
tolls uh IQ and social life not IQ sorry
genetics and social life and so anyway I
was du to give a talk at uh the uh
economics department at uh Glasgow and
this was in the time of covid and so I
call in and they say well just one
problem the dean had ordered that the
can the seminar be
there was a petition by a hundred
members of The
Faculty uh saying that they this was
pseudo science uh that Eugenics was to
be opposed in all of its
forms and so it was astonishing because
then the dean said well actually I've
looked at the paper and I don't see any
problem with the paper but the title is
a problem so if you would just change
the title we'll reschedule the seminar
are but then I felt on principle that I
can't really have the I don't care that
much about the title but I can't have
the dean tell me that and so that as I
say it was an astonishing turn in
universities that a bunch of people and
I'm sure most of those people are you
know Humanities or sociology or other
subjects like that feel that they can
actually call for
cancellation of of something else I mean
so that you you could imagine could come
and be critical and stuff like that but
but also I mean that that we'd reach
that stage and and effectively when they
did that there there was no cost to the
University of doing that right I thought
the the the dean and the principal at
the University played it very well
because as administrators because he
said well we're not canceling anything
there's just so much interest in this
talk that we think we need some kind of
enhan
security and so we're we're just
deferring things to to get to a better
place um but the funniest thing then was
that someone put me in touch with a
reporter from the
times and I thought well you know they
should publicize that these guys do
stuff like this and the times now is the
world's most worthless newspaper the
reporter for the Times had a story that
was headlined eugenesis denied
opportunity to speak at University
sake so so as a say it's it
is and and they couldn't even get my age
right or you know there were various
other things they couldn't get right in
the story and so so yes so that has
actually been uh a
concern uh and and I also noticed I mean
so when I'm doing this stuff you
know it's there's every possibility that
something is wrong that you haven't done
things correct L you know that's the
nature of doing these kind of
studies uh but I do notice that the the
kind of Twitter climate that surrounds
anything that has any hint about
genetics is brutal and unforgiving right
and people are just ready to go to the
barricades why do you think that
is I I honestly I don't really
understand why it's become kind of so
ingrained because for
example height is genetically determined
right and no one seems to get very upset
about that
fact uh and they do all of these studies
the same kind of studies they do for
Education they can tell you for everyone
here's what their height potential is uh
we know how it's transmitted we know
it's equally transmitted from mothers
and fathers and and you know and and so
people or eye color or other stuff like
that people simplifying that's perfectly
fine so why people somehow think that
because social characteristics are also
genetically potentially genetically
transmitted that it's time to kind of to
go to the barricades and to just you
know think of some reason why this
cannot be true you know use your theory
of mind what do you think this is a
threat to to them it's evidently a
threat to something yeah it's an
interesting question I mean why because
it's not just that people say oh I'm not
interested in that or you know don't
tell me that and stuff like that they
actively want to exclude any such
discussions from the academy right I
mean they they want to close down those
types of
Investigations uh and uh you know and
and and I to say I I I'm still a little
bit mystified as
to uh why you know why the in particular
this has become so uh controversial
right because I I say I've noticed now
I've read a bunch of stuff in behavioral
genetics and a lot of people who are
practicing behavioral genetics are very
busy trying to find reasons for why
behavioral genetics does not directly
affect that much about people's lives
right so where you know so now there's
this thing called genetic nurture I I
don't know if you've read about that no
what's this so it sounds awful it sounds
it sounds like it's going to annoy me
and I'm going to think about it for the
rest of the day right so here's an
interesting study that was done just a
couple years ago uh you inherit half of
your parents DNA on
average and so what they did was they
can type that DNA and say this is what
your educational potential is and so
what they did in the study in Iceland
was they took people's outcomes they had
their own DNA and then they had the DNA
they didn't inherit from their parents
they had no influence on their body
right because this was the stuff that
didn't get transmitted to them and then
they looked at predicting how many years
of education they would get as a
function of the DNA you did inherit and
the DNA you didn't inherit and it turns
out the DNA you didn't inherit is also
predictive of what your outcome is going
to be and it has about half the weight
of the DNA you actually inherited and
what they explanation then that they
proposed for this is that basically
maybe the way genetics is working is
that your parents because of the kind of
DNA they have set up a certain kind of
environment and a certain kind of
nurture for
you and that's actually what's doing the
work that's what's transmitting to the
Next Generation what your social status
is and then it's going to be correlated
with your DNA because you inherited the
DNA from the parents but it's not
directly the DNA that's doing the work
it's the environment that's actually so
much acrobatics and going on to
try and dance
around oh my god wow that's that's
really impressive I've got I've got a
circus I've actually got the image of a
circus in my mind at the moment as
someone doing like spirals through the
air yeah I don't know I so I I've had a
couple of conversations I had a
conversation with Paige harden a few
years ago that wrote the gentic lottery
uh Paige very very great researcher uh
Stuart Richie's been on the show pl's
been on the show Stuart Stuart's
fantastic Paige I I'm particularly
interesting uh because you know she's
somebody who is politically from the
left but uh scientifically um from the
behavioral genetics Camp a couple of
things that I can think of uh anything
that looks like G
genish like genetic type explanations
are immediately lambasted as being right
of Center or far right or you know
completely like bigoted um the academy
at the moment is left leaning uh and
becoming increasingly uh feminized as
well like just literally in the um
proportions of women that you have that
are attending as undergraduates and you
know this is going to grow into mostly
female professors over the next few
decades as well um some great research
by Corey Clark found that behavioral
genetics and evolutionary psychology
explanations were most likely to be
disliked by female professors um because
they are seen as being uh less
empathetic they're sort of less touchy
Philly they're less egalitarian uh
whereas the male professors were more
happy to have this come across so I
think generally you have this shift
toward a people not things or a empathy
not reality um approach um that that
could sway things in in one way and I
guess in another you know I come from a
a very workingclass background the the
only thing that was remarkable about
Stockton on teas was that it had the
highest teen pregnancy rating in the UK
and then after a while it it didn't it
didn't even have that anymore um it had
the
widest High Street in the UK as well I
think the widest pedestrian High Street
in the UK so really clutching at straws
to try and come up with something
um and you know I I feel very proud I
think I think I'm the first person in my
family to go to university I ended up
getting a masters as well and I I really
love the things that I do and I see in
myself I do feel sometimes like being
told that my
successes aren't mine to own quite so
much feels it feels disempowering in in
a way um it also feels reassuring in a
way because you can kind of go hands off
the wheel
in some regards but it does make you
think well hell like I I I
thought I worked really hard at that
thing and I did right I did I had to do
the thing and the thing was hard but for
someone to come along and say well yeah
but you didn't choose your
conscientiousness level and you didn't
choose your openness to experience and
you didn't choose your neuroticism and
you didn't choose your blah blah blah
and you're like yeah I get that uh and
it's a difficult Circle to square and
I'm I'm I'm still yet to work out how to
fully fold this into my world view you
know I'm I'm currently in London uh
about to do my live tour and I've got
these live shows that I'm doing and I'm
standing on stage and I'm telling people
on stage that they have way more control
over their outcomes than they think
because the bar is set incredibly low
because most people have externalized
their locus of control and if you take a
tiny little bit of work ethic and apply
it that you can make massive changes in
your life because I've seen this myself
but for me to square that circle with
this genetic predisposition thing is
really really difficult because I know
that there are things that people can do
that can give them better outcomes even
later into life because it happened to
me and yet over time genetics is this
you know this sort of gravitational
force that just sucks people toward
whatever they were supposed to be in any
case
uh I I agree with you that I mean it is
you know because the way we lead our
life is by making all these conscious
struggles and making these decisions and
and deciding to spend time on this as
opposed to something else and so it is
very hard to square with saying well
that's just that was just your the
lottery produced that's the type of
person you
are and uh yeah no and I agree for
motivational speakers the the news about
genetic transmission is not
great right guys I know that you were
coming here to feel empowered but we're
going to do an hour and a half on
behavioral genetics leave feeling
despondent good night
yeah wow I don't know basically
everything interesting that happened in
your life happened about 30 years
ago yeah yep yep well I mean you
know this was this was pl's pl's big
piece of advice like the single most
important decision that you can make in
your child's outcomes are who you have
them with and if you want to have if you
want to have a better child you know
don't bother reading books about diet
and neonatal care and and uh
optimal bedroom temperature for
neurological growth during the toddler
years and all the rest of it just spend
more time finding a smart partner right
like that's that's this that's the big
solution and it's disempowering and I
think that it pushes against a a
meritocratic world that says your
successes are yours to Bear uh alander
boton's got this beautiful beautiful
analogy I wish that he'd had a
conversation with PL or yourself or
someone cuz I think it would have been
really great he says um back in ancient
Greece the Beggars on the street were
referred to as unfortunates that lady
Fortuna hadn't blessed them right and uh
you'll remember lady Fortuna she's
holding a set of scales and the reason
that she's holding a set of scales is
that she gives and she takes away right
that there is supposed to be this Balan
to the universe which I think is a nice
excuse um for why some people have good
things and other people don't that
they'll get their comeuppance eventually
but if you roll the clock forward by
2,000 years what is it that we call
people who don't have anything going on
they're a loser right it's not that
they're unfortunate it's that if the
people who succeed are worthy of bearing
the fruits of their successes the people
who don't succeed are worthy of bearing
the losses of theirs as well and that's
why this language that kind of centers
the locus of control upon the individual
has has changed and that is you know
fundamentally what a meritocracy is uh
you are able to enact change in your
life your Merit is what will determine
your outcomes and there are relatively
few barriers in the way and it means
that for the people maybe this is a
luxury belief as well in some regards
people that are at the top they don't
want to be told that the only reason
that they manag to get into this High
futing institution was because of their
mothers mothers mothers fathers mothers
all the way
back yeah so I mean maybe you could say
well there is this always this random
element and maybe it's openness to to
kind of experience or stuff like that
can can increase that Randomness right
that that this would be the thing to say
look like half of your outcomes in some
sense depend on just random shocks and
so maybe there's a way of kind of
choosing to take more gambl in life
right and and uh right because for
example as an academic there's certain
types of paper you can write that are
just much more risky than others where
you know half the time it's going to
come to nothing you know more than half
the time 90% of the time but it might
kind of pay off it might you know go
somewhere roll the dice yeah so so and
that would be a a thing about what kind
of attitude you have to life right are
you going to be conservative or kind of
afraid of of these things or you know
but I suppose you know coming into it
well what have you got are you trying to
conserve or are you trying to explore
are you trying to hold on to what it is
that you have you know if you've managed
to come from a family that's from a
wealthy background maybe you do you like
let's just don't be the generation that
it up for you know great grandpa
who made a few million pounds doing
whatever whatever like let's just not be
you optimized to not be an idiot as
opposed to be a hero uh whereas someone
that's lower down the distribution you
would look to explore more than exploit
right we need to I've got very little to
lose my downside is limited my upside is
is basically asymmetric so yeah
fascinating fascinating Greg I I think
it's so interesting I'm really excited
for you to write this book I think it's
uh I think it's I I don't know what the
conclusion I think that what will be
really important when you do finally
sort of round all of this out will be to
try and put some sort of like I don't
know how does someone amarate this into
their life I think is what it's
fascinating all the way down super
interesting really really really cool
the question that everyone's going to be
left with is all right and now how am I
supposed to see the world and my self
right it's very difficult the one very
practical piece of advice I would say is
that as a modern society we are obsessed
with child rearing and with investing
enormous quantities of time and effort
in children and and we have a society
where increasingly it's not clear that
we're actually going to sustain
ourselves as a society right and so one
kind of interesting message I think
would be to say look there's not a lot
of evidence that all of that stuff
matters much just have children and
enjoy them right you don't have to go
through this excruciating kind of thing
called
parenting you could just relax have a
glass of
wine they'll be fine not while you're
pregnant not while you're pregnant after
that right but but you know and and that
actually would be one kind of I think in
an important lesson that actually people
would would need because I know as a a
first parent my s we went to ridiculous
extent in terms of what we did you know
as parents to try and determine and
predispose your child's outcomes despite
the fact that they're on a set of train
tracks that are heading to the same
destination yeah yeah and and and you
know if I could get all that time back
that's what I
want but uh anyway so so there are some
kind of uh upsides uh to this uh and um
and then you know but
as a person kind of intellectually it's
kind of nice to see that they really
even in the complicated social world
that we live in this idea that there
really is almost a kind of physics to
social life it's kind of attractive and
and kind of powerful uh so uh yeah so I
guess my big ambition though in life is
not to not to write a howto book
for for middle class parents
ameliorating Behavior genetics no I
understand Greg Clark ladies and
gentlemen Greg I think your work's
fantastic this really really interesting
I can't wait to see what you do next
where should people go if they want to
keep up to date with your work or read
more of the stuff that you've done so so
the article that just came out in
proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences is actually Open Access and
it's actually not that hard for people
to look at that and read that uh and
then you know I have if you just Google
my name I have a website with a bunch of
kind of work papers on various uh topics
that they they can do and then hopefully
in a year or so there'll actually be a
book
finally thanks my pleasure thank you
Gregory if you enjoyed that episode then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
weeks and don't forget to subscribe